the movie is set in a dystopian future
where technology has become
indispensable in performing just about
any task at the start a man named stripe
dreams about a beautiful woman soon he
wakes up and it is revealed that stripe
is a new military recruit he is set to
go on a mission with his Squad which
includes a female soldier named Hunter
Rayman and an arrogant Soldier Leonard
why the Leonards always have to be so
arrogant Stripes team has been tasked
with checking out an infestation of
roaches in a nearby Village roaches are
pale snarling humanoid monsters with
sharp teeth apparently these creatures
are vicious and they prey on innocent
people it is Stripes first field day
after his training so he is nervous and
scared but when Rayman encourages him he
gets riled up shortly after the squad
arrives at a village which has just been
looted by a bunch of roaches the
terrified villagers try to explain the
situation but they speak in a different
language which the soldiers can't
comprehend so the group's Commander
Medina takes out a translator and starts
interrogating the villagers she
eventually learns that the roaches
escaped in the direct section of someone
named Parn Heidecker Parn is a solitary
religious freak who is apparently
suffering from mental health issues the
locals claim that he let roaches cross
his land and even left out food for them
in the meantime stripe individually
speaks to the villagers and Promises to
one of them that he will try his best to
keep them safe suspecting that Parn is
helping the roaches the soldiers head
out for his compound it is then revealed
that each soldier in the military has a
neural implant called Mass embedded in
their brain which provides data via AR
or augmented reality Mass also helps the
military and strategic operations soon
the squad reaches parn's large compound
and plans their raid using holographic
maps and data displays which each
Soldier has access to thanks to the
implants in their brains Medina stripe
Rayman and Leonard are in charge of
talking to Parn and searching the main
house while the others are assigned with
raiding the nearby outer buildings
executing their mission Medina knocks on
the door and demands to inspect his home
a few seconds later a scared paren
answers and it appears as if he is the
only one home although reluctant at
first he lets the soldiers inside his
house Raymond and stripe quickly go
about searching upstairs while Medina
and Leonard interrogate Parn after
talking to him for a bit Medina notices
some religious symbols decorating the
walls this makes her realize that Parn
is simply looking out for the roaches
because of some religious beliefs that
all living species must be protected she
attempts to disabuse him of this notion
by discussing the supposed sickness in
the roach's blood which doesn't care
about ideals of common Humanity she also
tells him that the roaches need to be
exterminated if humanity is going to
survive Medina is starting to sound a
lot like a Hitler meanwhile stripe and
Rayman search the room upstairs to check
for any roaches they come across a
hidden room and decide to split up in
one room stripe sees a blanket with
multiple Shadows behind it when he lifts
the blanket he finds three terrifying
roaches there the roaches appear to be
pale humanoids with sharp teeth
flattened noses and discolored eyes
Voldemort would be proud one of them
holds up a mysterious device with a
green light stripe immediately shoots
one in the head and starts tussling with
another as the creature attempts to bite
him he draws out his knife and stabs the
roach in the chest even after it is dead
a disturbed stripe continues stabbing it
after the encounter he examines the
mysterious green light device and
experiences a flash which causes a
slight strain in his eyes as Rayman
rushes to help him she has knocked down
the stairs by an escaping roach at the
same time Pawn attempts to stab Medina
but he is easily subdued and taken into
custody before heading back to their
base Medina decides to set the compound
on fire which also destroys the
mysterious green light device the next
day Rayman is seen practicing her Sharp
Shooting against roach targets so that
none get away the next time it is
evident that she is envious of a newbie
like stripe killing two Roaches on his
first day soon stripe arrives and joins
in on the exercise he aims at his Target
but suddenly his neural implant glitches
and he ends up missing this worries
Rayman but stripe insists that he is
fine however during push-up exercises
his neural implant continues to glitch
which affects his performance Medina
notices this and orders him to see a
doctor resolving to get to the bottom of
the issue stripe follows his Commander's
orders and goes to the military hospital
the doctor runs a diagnostic test on
Stripes implant but fails to find
anything wrong after a while stripe
tries to open up about the green device
which he found at parn's compound but
the doctor doesn't understand anything
and simply refers to a person called
Arquette it turns out Arquette is a
resident military psychologist he
suspects that Stripes problem may have
something to do with the fact that he
killed two roaches brutally he also
claims that a few days of proper rest
should resolve everything before parting
ways Arquette promises to stripe an
extremely good sleep by programming
something special for his dreams that
night this dream involves the return of
Stripes recurring fantasy of the
beautiful woman surrounded by flowing
drapes this time though it's more
intense the lights are red and she asks
him to have coitus with her stripe gives
in and the two have a wonderful time but
just then the glitch turns up again
forcing him to wake up he sits up up in
his bunk and looks over his comrades who
are all peacefully sleeping the next day
stripe Raymond and Medina are back in
the village helping out with food and
supplies there Medina informs the group
that a piece of information was
extracted on the roach's whereabouts
from Parn hence the squad heads out to
the said location to perform a Recon
after a while the trio arrives at an
abandoned area and plans their Recon
with the help of a drone and their Mass
implants as the group continues
discussing Stripes implant glitches out
yet again and malfunctions suddenly he
realizes that he can smell the grass
which he could not before when the
implant was working he tries to explain
it to Rayman but she simply ignores him
all of a sudden shots are fired and
Medina is struck in the head instantly
killing her despite the setback Rayman
somehow retrieves the Drone from the
crossfire and uses it to locate the
shooter it turns out that the roaches
are holed up in a room with a stolen
rifle stripe seems distraught but Rayman
decides to make their way into the
compound providing cover fire for each
other stripe who is still confused and
dizzy after the implant stopped working
reluctantly agrees and follows his
comrade there the two find a kind of
makeshift electronic Workshop probably
the source of that green light device
from earlier shortly after stripe finds
something even more surprising he sees a
normal looking woman hiding out in one
of the rooms begging for her life she
doesn't look like a roach so stripe
tells her to get out of there promising
not to hurt her she slowly backs into
the hallway attempting to flee but
shockingly Rayman shoots her dead this
stunned stripe and he questions why she
killed a civilian but she simply brushes
him aside and moves forward going on a
killing spree mowing down all the
roaches in the building strangely from
Stripes perspective all the roaches she
kills look like normal humans which
shocks him even more Raymond then
proceeds to kill a frightened mother-son
Duo but before she can do so stripe
intervenes and knocks her unconscious
sadly he also gets shot in the process
after a while he staggers to his feet
and escapes with the mother and son
while profusely bleeding as stripe leads
them to safety Rayman wakes up and
Witnesses them getting in the military
vehicle and fleeing after having been
shot in the belly and losing a lot of
blood stripe passes out behind the wheel
making the car come to a complete stop
in the middle of the woods then the
woman dragged stripe into her Small
hidden cave made up of twigs and dirt
and begins to treat his wound he soon
regains Consciousness and gets startled
by the woman applying bandages on his
wound the woman introduces herself as
Katarina and her son is Alec she then
drops a major Revelation it turns out
that the roaches the military has been
hunting are just normal beings it is the
mass implant that alters The Soldier's
senses and makes them look like inhumane
monsters this is because the higher
class people look upon the roaches as
some disease-ridden poor and
unintelligent beings Katarina also
reveals that the green light device used
on stripe was built by her friend to
mess with the implants to make the
soldiers see the roaches as their real
selves I.E humans the roaches are
victims of a genocide justified by the
military as genetic cleansing damn I
didn't expect my Hitler joke to hit so
deep a stunned stripe asks why the Ville
villagers hate the roaches despite them
having no such implants Katarina
responds that while the locals see the
roaches as humans they still treat them
as inferior due to propaganda turns out
that 10 years ago the government ran DNA
checks all around the world which
changed everything people with genetic
predispositions to illness were
categorized as roaches which was a
campaign set in motion by television and
Internet media unfortunately as the two
continue talking Rayman tracks them down
the two roaches try running away but
they are immediately shot and killed
this traumatizes stripe and he breathes
heavily as Rayman walks up to him while
pointing her gun at him she then demands
an explanation for his earlier betrayal
but stripe who is still in a State of
Shock and remorse keeps murmuring to
himself none of this is true sadly this
only puzzles Rayman and she knocks him
out with her gun in the next scene
stripe wakes up in a white-walled Cell
crouching in the corner soon Arquette
pays him a visit and offers him coffee
he also apologizes to stripe for failing
to catch the glitch in his neural
implants sooner the psychologist then
explains that the green device he found
in The Farmhouse was reverse engineered
by the roaches from some of the
military's drone Parts the light in the
device transmits a code which is like a
virus it Burrows into one's mass and
tries to shut it down from within
however stripe calls everything a lie
and insists that the roaches look just
like them Arquette acknowledges it but
also claims that the roaches are
dangerous he then adds that humans are
genuinely empathetic as a species and
this is why creatures like the roaches
are taking advantage of them following
this Arquette gives the example of World
War II during which most soldiers didn't
fire their weapons or if they did they
would just aim over the heads of their
enemies on purpose in numbers only 15 to
20 percent of the soldiers would pull
the trigger the fate of the world was at
stake but only a small fraction of them
fired Arquette comments that the war
would have been over a whole lot quicker
had the military grown some cajones and
did their job because of this the
officials had to figure out a way to
work around humans natural empathy as
many soldiers were afraid to kill
Arquette reveals that mass Alters
soldiers senses such as smell and sound
so that they can kill without hesitate
remorse he then shows a video evidence
where stripe consented to the memory and
sense altering effects of the mass
procedure it turns out that after stripe
was implanted with the mass all of his
previous memories were erased Furious
stripe attempts to attack our cat but
the latter uses the implant to Blind him
the cunning psychologist then offers him
two choices stripe can either allow the
military to reset his implant wiping out
his memory of the past few days and this
very conversation or to be incarcerated
forever initially stripe chooses to be
incarcerated to help him reconsider
Arquette plays the footage of the first
mission in his mind however in this
footage stripe sees the real events that
unfolded without the alteration of the
mass system he Witnesses himself
brutally murdering and stabbing normal
people which he then saw as roaches he
also learns that the roach that had
escaped from Stripes first mission was
actually Katarina as expected the
footage breaks Stripe from the inside
and he eventually decides to wipe out
his memory of the past few days in the
final scene stripe now a decorated
officer leaves his base and approaches a
house he has tears streaming down his
face as he smiles and watches the girl
from his dreams walk towards him from
the empty and dilapidated house damn
Black Mirror you scary subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching